-Why is everyone bringing me
gifts today?
-It's Giving Tuesday.
-It is giving, yes.
-So I thought I would give you
some of these.
They've only just come out.
Hopefully they fit you.
They're Avatar sneakers.
They're skate shoes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No way.
-Yeah.
-Come on, that's what
I'm talking about, bud.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's a friend.
-You're welcome.
-That's a friend right there.
Thank you very much for these.
I appreciate them.
-I think they glow
in the dark too.
They light up like
bioluminescence.
-Come on. Dude, is that right?
-So when you skate in the dark,
as you do.
-Yeah, I do skate. I do skate
in the dark. It'll glow?
-Yeah.
-Thanks for coming back.
But I haven't seen you
in so long.
-It's been a while.
-You're a great friend
of our show.
Thank you for coming back
because when we first started in
"Late Night,"
you came on back in 2010.
-A lot's changed. Yeah.
-You have three kids now.
-Yeah.
-Congratulations.
-And same to you.
-Yeah, I have two kids.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How old are the kids?
-7, 6, and 2 1/2.
-Is that right?
-So it's a zoo.
-It is a zoo, huh?
-Yeah, and they're born
in America.
I love America. One was born
in -- two were born in L.A.
[ Cheers ]
Yep, and one was born
in New York
because I wanted that rivalry.
-Oh that's smart.
Yeah, East Coast, West Coast.
That's so smart, yeah.
-One's Biggie,
one's Tupac for sure.
[ Laughter ]
-Do they have accents?
Australian accents?
-No, they've got
American accents.
-They do?
-Yeah, yeah.
And they make fun of my accent
all the time.
[ Laughter ]
Like, "G'day, Dad. How are ya?"
It's actually a really bad
accent that they do.
-That's fun. That's great.
-Well, no, it's embarrassing.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, of course.
But that's what kids do.
You look great, by the way.
You look like a stud.
You brought a photo of you
not too long ago.
Here's you -- This is me with a
beard. Here is you with a beard.
Boi-oi-oing!
-Yeah, that was my COVID beard.
Took about nine months,
and then I kind of went,
"Well, I want to get a job
where I could actually
put that in a film"
'cause you have to.
-I mean, you put a lot of work
into growing the beard.
-I did a Western.
And I was terrible in it, but
the beard will win an Oscar.
[ Laughter ]
-Congratulations.
An early congratulations on
the beard winning an Oscar.
You got to come back
when that comes out.
Let's talk about "Avatar,"
which is I think oddly
what we did years ago.
-Yeah, yeah.
-We talked about "Avatar."
And then they were like, "Yeah,
we're going to make sequels.
We're going to make three.
We're going to make four."
This is --
-I saw it last night.
It literally got locked off
on Saturday.
A couple of days ago,
and then we saw it yesterday.
-What did you think?
-It's that, man.
-Really?
-It's the first one,
it blows it away.
I get quite emotional
talking about it
'cause what Jim's done,
he's made it about a family.
And it's powerful.
It's powerful.
Not only is it visually stunning
and you're seeing a part of
Pandora that you've never seen
before, all under water,
but it's about what you do
to protect your family.
And I think after COVID,
I think everybody needs
that kind of message.
And it's about what you would do
for those that you love.
-Wow.
-Yeah, it's amazing.
-It's amazing how you can do
this with the technology.
I remember seeing the first
"Avatar" and going like,
"Oh, I'll be into this.
This is a 3-D movie."
And I go, "It'll be a cartoon
or whatever it is."
-Well, this one, we literally --
we do scenes --
I did a scene with a kid;
he plays my son.
And it's about -- you know,
the whole way through,
the fathers and sons
are disconnected.
And just like teenage boys,
they're struggling to find
their place in the world.
And we're doing the scene and I
realize I'm 30 feet under water.
And that's how we do
these scenes.
We put emotional scenes
in a big tank with no scuba.
We all learned how to free dive,
this great technique.
-Yeah, we had Sigourney Weaver
on and she said she learned --
-She's part fish.
It's incredible.
[ Laughter ]
-Is she really?
-She's got gills.
But no, it's amazing.
-How long can you hold
your breath underwater?
-Well, Kate Winslet
did seven minutes.
Sigourney did about six.
I did easy 15 seconds.
[ Laughter ]
-So your scenes are very quick.
-No, but the thing was,
when you're under that deep,
you have to forget that
you're under the water.
And as I said, the scene between
me and this boy,
he just reached out
and squeezed my hand
and brought me
back into the scene.
And you forget
how submerged you are.
These scenes are hard enough
to do on dry land
and we're just crazy enough
to put them underwater.
-Yeah, just acting in general.
I go, "Oh, that's amazing."
But then, yeah,
like you're saying --
-Deep dive, yeah.
-Five minutes and you go like,
when they say "cut,"
you still have to go --
-You can hear Jim
under the water too.
So he directs you through
these sound systems in the tank.
And that's this voice
in your head going --
-How long does it take you
to get out of the water?
-I'm 46.
It took me a long time.
[ Laughter ]
-Don't you go like,
"Hey, when you say cut,
I got another 10 seconds
before I get oxygen"?
-They would bring the scuba over
on cut and I wouldn't come up.
It was easier for me
to stay down there
because it was a long way up, so
I would spend hours down there.
And the rest of the camera team
is down there with you,
and safety coordinators.
But I would do my breathe-ups
under the water.
It was quite calm. Yeah.
-Oh, my gosh.
You just really lived --
-You come out like a prune.
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
I know this is the second one,
"The Way of Water,"
and there's rumors that
there's five in the works.
How many have you filmed?
Can you say?
-We've filmed about
80%, 90% of three.
I think we're still
owing some scenes.
And in four, we did a few scenes
because the kids were aging out.
So we have to go --
-Do it before they get older.
-Before they get a bit older.
And then yeah,
there's five in the saga
if we're lucky enough to get it.
We're not arrogant enough to
assume it's going to connect.
We really hope so because we
love the movie
and hope other people do too.
-Congratulations on this
and the first one.
And thank you for coming back.
Thank you for my gift.
-You're welcome.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Sam Worthington in
"Avatar: The Way of Water."
Take a look this.
-If the people harbor us,
they will die.
Do you understand?
Look, I got nothing.
I got no plan.
But I can protect this family.
That I can do.
But I know one thing.
Wherever we go,
this family is our fortress.
-Yeah, that's Sam Worthington,
everybody!
"Avatar: The Way of Water" is in
theaters and IMAX December 16th.